ça peut sembler étonnant mais notre
survie dépend de la santé des océans et
services qu'ils nous rendent sont
immenses
ils nourrissent ils sont aussi
d'importants régulateur du climat mais
les océans sont malades et les maux qui
les afflige ne cesse de prendre de
l'ampleur alors est il trop tard pour
agir
y a t-il raison d'espérer voici un bilan
de santé des océans
[Musique]
la terre la planète bleue c'est ici que
nous habitons 8 milliards d'humains y
vivent entourés d'eau salée des océans
essentiels à la vie et qui sent de plus
en plus fragilisé
à tel point que notre existence sur
cette planète pourrait bien ne plus
jamais être comme avant
je crois que je suis optimiste mais
quand s'agit l'océan aujourd'hui je suis
inquiète
[Musique]
peu d'entre nous ont observé la terre
comme cathy sort leuven
[Musique]
cet astronaute américaine est aussi
océanographe et le regard qu'elle porte
sur notre planète est unique
j'avais l'impression si maman de
fragilité et de pouvoir de notre planète
on voit des orages très grand au des
courants aux signaux graphiques des
centaines de kilomètres si notamment la
fragilité élégance et pouvoir grande
poubelle
on a donné cette planète de mauvais non
on a nommé tél
on est de le nommer à quoi à quoi c'est
le moule atteint pour oh il y en a à la
grandeur du globe
71 % de la surface de la terre et
recouvertes par des océans qui sont
interconnectées cela représente un
volume immense de 1,37 milliard de
kilomètres cubes d'eau salée encore très
largement inexploré
[Musique]
reste encore à découvrir
plus de 90% des espèces présentes dans
les océans n'aurait pas encore été
répertoriés
il ya de la vie partout autant dans la
colonne d'eau que sur les fonds marins
du plateau continental près des rives
eaux plus profondes fosses abyssales des
organismes microscopiques
jusqu'aux plus grands êtres vivants
c'est énorme garde manger nourrit les
humains depuis la nuit des temps
[Musique]
et les scientifiques d'aujourd'hui crois
même pouvoir y trouver les remèdes aux
maladies de demain
[Musique]
you sion pour moi ça représente la vie
c'est à cause de l'océan de ce planète
que nous vivons la moitié de l'oxygène
que nous respirons ça devient direct de
lotion
en plus d'être notre principale source
d'oxygène les océans influence largement
le climat de la planète
il absorbe la chaleur de l'atmosphère et
sont aussi de véritables puits qui cap
sur le gaz carbonique
mais malgré leur grande résilience
les océans sont à bout de souffle et ce
n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
je
là pour moi ça a renforcé une obligation
de souvenirs que que je suis connecté
richement qu'on a fait avec toutes parts
et planète et il me faut le bien soigné
c'est la seule planète omra
cathy sort leuven n'est pas la seule à
sonner l'alarmé en 2019
le groupe d'experts intergouvernemental
sur l'évolution du climat le giec a
déposé un rapport spécial sur l'océan
lors d'une conférence à monaco son
constat a de quoi faire frémir dans le
monde entier les océans subissent les
ardeurs du changement climatique
depuis des décennies ce qui a des
conséquences radicales et profonde sur
la nature et l'humanité
en tant que
espèce les humains sont entrés de
modifier les océans de telle façon qu'on
risque de vraiment leur nuire au niveau
de la bio diversité et l'abondance de
plusieurs espèces de poissons et
invertébrés marins au québec
le physicien denis gilbert est inquiet
le chercheur à l'institut maurice
lamontagne a fait partie de la
délégation canadienne qui a travaillé à
l'adoption du rapport du giec à monaco
ma réaction principal par rapport aux
rapaces et qu' il est plus que temps que
les humains brin d'en contrôler leurs
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
avec les niveaux de co2 actuel qui
continue d'augmenter
parce qu'on utilise encore énormément de
charbon de gaz naturel et de pétrole la
tendance nude actuelle me force à être
pessimiste
[Musique]
le système climatique de la terre et
régis principalement par les échanges
d'énergie entre l'océan et l'atmosphère
avec l'augmentation du co2 la
température de la planète se réchauffe
entraînant aussi la hausse des océans et
cela provoque son lot de bouleversements
peter galbraith est un peu comme un
docteur au chevet d'un malade son
patient le grand système que constitue
le saint laurent
donc il y à peu près une dizaine
d'années les choses ont commencé à
vraiment changé dans gaulle sa roue
mon rôle est devenu beaucoup plus
important dans ce sens coulisses pense
quelque chose à ce pic en servant faut
pas le manquer le chercheur à l'institut
maurice-lamontagne analyse la
température des eaux afin de quantifier
les changements qui affectent les
organismes marins
son diagnostic est sans équivoque
depuis ces dernières années les eaux du
saint-laurent ne cesse de se réchauffer
commencé avec le font chaque année c'est
un petit peu plus chaud chaque année on
brise le regard donc on y déjà dans des
températures que le golf dans les
salaires année à pau connu l'eau n'est
pas homogène dans le système du saint
laurent
on retrouve trois couches superposées
qui se réchauffe pour des raisons
différentes
l'enjeu en surface c'est la perte du
couvert de glace en hiver qu'on voit
poindre à l'horizon
as projeta juste une cinquantaine
d'années dans le futur ben on va voir
que le golfe saint laurent va devenir un
peu comme halifax les maintenant à ou la
glace de mer ne se rend pas à l'ifa ça
va être mon histoire pour le golfe
saint-laurent où la glace bord va se
former jusqu'à complète aux labos
l'armée on
repos dans le golfe sont sauf exception
dénis très fortement froide
peter galbraith est particulièrement
inquiet de ce qui arrive à la couche
d'eau profonde
là où vivent de nombreux organismes
marins cette couche n'est pas en contact
avec l'atmosphère et elle est
indépendante des couches supérieures
sa température est influencé par les
grands courants océaniques de
l'atlantique qui eux ont commencé à être
perturbée par les changements
climatiques
donc ces eaux là nous viennent du bout
du chenal laurentien à l'extrémité
complet en dehors du golfe puis se
mélangent l'oeil de plus en plus riches
en eau chaude on qu'on sait que pour les
quelques prochaines années tout le moins
ça va continuer réchauffer on doit s'en
inquiéter parce que on est sortis de
l'envelope du connu
le réchauffement des océans a un impact
bien tangible sur les humains
principalement pour les populations
côtières et insulaires
c'est que le niveau de l'eau s'est mise
à monter et ce phénomène n'est pas près
de s'arrêter
l'éléphant dans la pièce qui fait peur à
tout le monde c'est la fonte des
calottes glaciaires celle du groenland
et de l'antarctique
il y à peu près deux décennies ces
fontes le guen année en antarctique
était relativement
dans ces deux endroits là il ya une
accélération du phénomène selon le giec
au cours du siècle le niveau de la mer
continuera d'augmenter comme jamais et
cette hausse pourrait atteindre 30 à 60
cm d'ici 2100
jumelé à l'intensification des
phénomènes météo extrêmes les
conséquences seront majeurs plusieurs
villes côtières et des îles de faible
élévation vont ils goûtent et comme un
billet mis dernièrement la conséquence
principale de
la hausse du niveau de la mer c'est que
plusieurs grandes métropoles vont être
infectées et vont devoir
savard attire toutes sortes de défense
pour protéger les infrastructures la vie
d'une grande partie de l'humanité sera
chamboulée environ 30% de la population
mondiale habite à moins de 100
kilomètres d'une compte
on peut s'imaginer des villes comme
shanghai des villes comme new york
essayer de se protéger
ici la ville de québec est un endroit où
il va avoir aussi des effets de la
hausse du niveau de la mer les humains
auront beau essayer de se protéger
il y à un autre problème auquel
échapperont pas
les océans nous doit faire un grand
service à l'humanité c'est qu'ils
absorbent une grande partie du gaz
carbonique qu'on aimait mais ce
service-là via un coup c qui vient
acidifier les eaux océanes et
[Musique]
les océans absorbent plus du quart des
émissions de co2 produites par l'homme
chaque année ce dioxyde de carbone se
dissout dans l'eau et forme de l'acide
carbonique
conséquence son ph diminue et l'océan
c'est si difficile processus qui
risquent de s'intensifier à proximité de
la surface où l'on retrouve une grande
partie des espèces exploitées par
l'homme on est en train de faire une
expérience avec le co2 qui à la
potentielle d'appauvrir énormément les
océans les organismes qui possède une
structure calcaire seraient touchés on
pense ici au plancton à la base de la
chaîne alimentaire
certains mollusques et crustacés aussi
pourrait avoir de la difficulté à former
leur coquille et leur squelette externe
enfin les coraux qui sont une formidable
pouponnière pour les poissons risquent
d'avoir de plus en plus de difficultés à
survivre
[Musique]
le bilan pour les océans est sombre
et les défis sont nombreux
arriverons-nous renverser la vapeur
[Musique]
adèle réchauffement arrêter la
signification pour cela il s'agit
d'arrêter les émissions en tout cas bon
bull en hausse perd cela c'est ça la
question
[Musique]